[музика]
А це нас будуть млинці з червоною рибою
з сиром
Джек дуже Чисто і апетитно так виглядало
воно переробили все нічого не Лишилося
тільки вікно фасадне
за їхніми спинами черга тільки зліпили
вареники їх одразу ж розбирають
у носі що неподалік Дюссельдорфа на
північному заході Німеччини українці
відкрили продовольчу крамницю де можна
купити вареники голубці сирники млинці
та інші українські страви з
різноманітними начинками
придбати ці продукти було можливо Тільки
щось схоже там пельмені вареники в
російських магазинах враховуючи зараз
наші відносини з Росією відповідно рука
не піднімалася туди йти І лишати там
кошти і виникла ідея створити по-перше
робочі місця для наших дівчат які тут
переїхали ні знання мови бар'єри і
психологічні і
мовні бар'єри дуже важко знайти їм було
роботу мені здалося це одна як з візі і
компанія це працевлаштування наших
друге було питання це
заповнити ніж якої немає а клієнти На
даному етапі появились
відповідно тільки в одній Німеччині
знаходиться мільйон наших українців які
вимушено переїхали
персонал повністю український лише на
кайсі дівчина з Литви яка вільно
говорить німецькою щоб пояснювати німцям
особливості української кухні загалом
восьмеро людей усі оформлення офіційно
запевняють що зарплати гідні Оксана
Мілько до кулінарії взагалі ніякого
відношення немає Вона за фахом біохімік
до війни працювала в лабораторії при
лікарні у Балаклії на Харківщині а
мешкала У сусідньому Селищі пришив
ми приїхали тому що вже сили не було
терпіти обстрілювали село на протязі 6
місяців кожен день
Тому вже діватись було ніколи нікуди
Коли почали наші наступати бої
інтенсифікація пішла і Ми вимушені були
тікати
Оксана та її мама виїхали з України два
місяці тому каже як і чимало інших
українців не звикли просто сидіти вдома
і знайшли роботу через інтернет на сайті
з оголошеннями про вакансії
ми
не одразу виїхали в Німеччину Ми
спочатку виїхали в Польщу і там ми теж
не ставали на облік як біженці Ми з
матір'ю відразу Пішли працювати на завод
тому що потрібно було чимось зайняти
місце а не сидіти кожен день читати
новини це так загуби можна зійти тому ми
вирішили попрацювати ну якраз така
механічна робота такі процеси
відволікають
воно затягує і ти менше думаєш про
все Це жахіття Яке зараз твориться на
Україні
ця на перший погляд монотонна робота
своєрідна психотерапія для біженців з
України а з іншого боку своєрідне шоу
для перехожих люди зупиняються
роздивляються фотографують для місцевих
це щось незвичне й оригінальне магія
створення вареників зачаровує
місцева жителька генрієте ще ніколи не
куштувала українських страв Вона
замовила вареники з вишнею і сиром
Я купую Сподіваюся правильно вимовляю
вареники Я живу неподалік побачила це а
також прочитала в газеті що тут
українські страви
Ми багато робимо зокрема осьодорфі для
українських біженців І звісно Треба
спробувати цю їжу
я не дуже знаю що це таке але потім ще
почитаю
вареники з картоплею коштують 7 євро за
кілограм за німецькими мірками це не
дорого приблизно як два пива
вареники з капустою і грибами 8 євро А
голубці зі свинини та яловичини 13 євро
сирники класичні 11 євро також є
пельмені хінкалі та інші страви
Треба ж було одружитися на Одесі щоб
купувати це все в магазині що таке
дівчата зробили сказали що сма
Оксана родом з Одеси живе У сусідньому
Дюссельдорфі крамниця лише декілька днів
як відкрилася а сарафани радіо вже
працює
наша подружжя наша подруга дізналася А
їй сказав Саша податковий радник тобто
він сказав і передали далі І далі А ми
тепер будемо теж далі передавати
шеф-кухар гастроомей Олександр данканич
здобув освіту в Англії де вивчав
класичну французьку кухню а зараз готує
українську в Німеччині йому сподобалася
ідея Дениса поширити український дух і
смак у Німеччині я починав з рецептів
бабусі Ну скажу чесно не своєю з
колегиною бабусі Він казав що вона
робить чудові вареники починали з тіста
яке було шикарне і начинки так само але
потім виявилось так що коли ми перейшли
на професійну велику кухню то можете
перестали працювати так як в домашніх
умовах
напевно із-за того що коли це тісто
містить тепла рука і коли це містить
чисто машинка в нашому випадку ми на
такі об'єми почну саме тісто вимісити не
зможемо то по-іншому получається
запускається процес і нам потрібно було
це все як то кажуть відробляти Швидко
щоб ми могли підготувати хороший рецепт
до запуску вже основа меню українська
класика а саме вареники у різних
варіаціях з додаванням душі хисту та
досвіду яка каже сам Олександр з
некласичних начинок вареники з малиною і
сиром загалом 34 позиції у меню на даний
момент
пізні начинки різновиди таких страв як
налисники
деруни в нас є звичайні картопляні
деруни з цукіні дуже смачні багато
навіть колег на кухні от ніколи не
пробували їх сказали що дуже цікава ідея
дуже цікавий рецепт надіюсь що і нашим
покупцям теж воно дуже зайде Я завжди
синхронізувався з продуктами які я роблю
я я його відчував і тому коли я
розробляв рецепт чи сирників чи якогось
начинки
ну це трошки в мене як якийсь
медитативний стан який Я входжу я
починаю чувати консистенцію наприклад
ворога і так далі І я Ну як кажуть
вкладаю свою душу і щоб вона
відображалася в тому рецепті
А це обговорюють новий рецепт знімати
близько не можна
[музика]
А що далі по рецепту говорити і
показувати не можна авторське право
смачна таємниця
а от власне поява українського
продовольчого магазину вже не таємниця
про гастроому з позитивним відгуком
написала місцева газета стаття
називається як троє українців знайомлять
з Батьківщиною
крім того українська крамниця вже
інтегрована у місцевий харчовий ланцюжок
у сферами локальними підбираємо
все особисто на наших повар їде на поле
на склади фермера відбирає і намагаємося
використовувати тільки якісні продукти у
приміщенні ДТП українські страви раніше
торгували пончиками а потім була
бургерна так виглядало вона переробили
все нічого не Лишилося тільки вікно
фасадне все остальне було змінено плитка
стіни Кухня все було під ноль знесено і
все було зроблено з чистого листа
назвалися гастроома тобто гастрономічна
бабуся бо передбачають що основні
клієнти будуть все ж таки не українські
біженці а німці які мають хороший дохід
і готові витрачати свої кошти на ручну
роботу та якісні смачні продукти
німецькі бабусі українську гастрономічну
бабусю вже оцінили
подивись що в мене тут є як чудово
прекрасно ще й купон на скидку
[музика]
я оце купила деруни з цукіні
Я маю вже швидко додому йти Поки вони не
розтанули мої українські гості будуть
точно Раді
серед тих хто ліпить вареники і
військовий пенсіонер Віталій з Миколаєва
він був змушений виїхати через півтора
місяця після початку війни спершу в
Хорватію а потім у Німеччину працювати в
жіночому колективі йому подобається каже
дівчата не стільки роблять зауваження
Скільки дають поради
[музика]
вареник зліпити ось тут треба сильніше
щоб він не розвалювався тобто Ось такі
нюанси зауваження на що треба звернути
увагу на те що зауваження Що ти там не
так а це ось так а просто люди
підказують В кого є Які досвід господині
вдома чи людина працювала на такому
виробництві то звісно знає як це у
промисловому масштабі робити
Віталій працює у сімейному дуеті у його
дружини Ольги Сьогодні перший робочий
день
да добре нажимаєш добре
друзі
ось яке в нього борщ і макарони
по-флотськи
Це я так думаю що моя найбільш козирна
страва макарони по-флотськи я був в
Італії ходив купував сказали що з м'ясом
макарони паста болоньєзе я довго в цих
макаронах шукав м'ясо
Справа в тому що коли я роблю то в мене
у фарші треба ще пошукати макарони це
мені більше подобається з різноманітною
піджаркою я роблю це значно смачніше
щоб відкрити такий заклад у Німеччині
Денису та його колегам знадобилося
півроку спеціально взяли приміщення де
раніше теж була гастрономія що було
легше з різними бюрократичними дозволами
це воно не було тобто
на астрономію відповідно Це мінімум 8-12
місяців пройти всі етапи покроково в
Німеччині це все зробити
бізнес-план дизайн візуалізація розробка
бренду і логотипу розробка рецептури все
це Вже позаду було нелегко зізнається
Денис бо мета вгодити не лише українцям
а й німцям туркам та іншим діаспорам які
живуть у Німеччині тож роблять і
бургерні котлети і шніцелі працюють лише
декілька днів і збирають відгуки чого не
вистачає хто з якою начинкою І що саме
полюбляє Денис також створив своєрідний
ланцюжок взаємодопомоги не лише для
українських біженців за кордоном а й для
внутрішніх переселенців самій Україні
для нашого декору передавались з України
ну в Німеччині ми не змогли таке знайти
А якщо навіть є там на eBay на амазоні
то воно коштує тут дуже дорого тобто Ми
замовляли ну це виробляється зараз коли
воно вироблялося в славянському
коли почалась війна виробник переїхав в
Хмельницьку область і виробляється зараз
усе глиняна глиняний посуд виробляється
в кам'янець-подільському Хмельницької
області Денис не мислить локально а
хотів би створити цілу мережу покритий і
інші регіони Німеччини вже готують
франшизу щоб інші українці чи німці
могли відкрити такі самі бізнес
працювати на себе та надавати робочі
місця іншим Дениса з колегами першими
придумали в Німеччині такий формат і
сподіваються що все вдасться а поки на
черзі нова партія смакоти це нас будуть
мли
з червоною рибою з рибою і сиром
лосось перехожі на вулиці вже ковтають
слину і міркують щоб замовити навіть цей
пам'ятник робітнику що знаходиться
неподалік крамниці наче теж відчуває
запах українських страв і хотів би
скуштувати вареників та млинців